is he seriously assigning me to the
records room
i mean why do we even have a records
room computer's been invented right i
didn't dream it
you're lucky man i wish i could get a
sign here full-time
you could not be farther from the action
sergeant you know me i have more arrests
than anyone will you please tell the
captain how dumb it is to lock his best
detective in a file cabinet second best
you wrong about hoe that man has
forgotten more about being a cop than
you will ever know
in 1981 he caught the disco strangler
it's over disco man put down the yo-yo
and back away from the girl
[Music]
wow the man is the real deal you need to
listen to him
boyle will you please read the
transcripts of the threats he's received
yup
die die die die holt die okay little
obvious
you will drown in your own blood better
although i would have gone with the hole
i'm gonna staple my face onto your face
thing human skin mask
classic the next one is i'm gonna send
you off the deep end
drowning and deep end almost sounds like
he's talking about a swimming pool
it's hames aha who's hames colin haynes
the freestyle killer he took out an
entire 4x100 meter relay swim team in
1982.
marco no you say polo
punk the freestyle killer man
how come all the killers you caught had
such cool names the best name i ever
brought in was narrow shoes sam
because his shoes were narrow and his
name was sam i get it yeah you get it
peralta for the last time we don't have
to go back to the precinct i don't need
everyone's help
look captain you're stubborn and that's
an adorable quality
but you want to know what's not an
adorable quality being dead
being dead i mean i give up what's going
on with you why are you being so weird
about this
i don't need your help i don't want to
involve you or boyle
or anyone because i brought this
situation on myself no one should get
hurt because of a dumb mistake i made as
a brash young detective
hey james you're going to spend the rest
of your life in a little cement room
doing nothing and while you're in there
i'm gonna go for a swim
and after that swim i might take another
swim and you'll just be sitting here
on your metal toilet thinking of me
swim swim swimming all
day long when i get out of lockup i'm
gonna hunt you down
and kill you yeah
right
huh why would a psycho want to work here
gotcha
looking for me nope just taking my gun
for a walk through the nightmares
factory
nice try cop but you and i are gonna
have a little tea party
am i invited drop the weapon
okay slayer prepare to go to jail for
ooh
long time no say punk
punk punk i
said it captain i'm sorry to interrupt i
just got off the phone with the
department of corrections they wanted me
to let you know that ernest zamowski
died
my goodness it's been a while since i've
heard that name
i hunted him for years and finally
caught him and put an end to his
bloodlust
in some sick way i am who i am because
of ernest zumawski aka
the disco strangler oh so you knew who i
was talking about yeah sure you talk
about him a lot you know the yo-yo was
his calling card
oh i mentioned that too so how'd he die
he was in a prison transport van and he
got in a terrible accident
it burst into flames he was trapped
inside
well well well he finally did it died
horribly escaped
just like he said he would all those
years ago i'll be coming back for you
i'm just like disco baby i will never
die true
disco will never die but you will in
yourself
punk oh so i've told that part of the
story as well yes
at every christmas party all right
people
your suspect's name is ernest zamowski
better known
as the disco strangler take a close look
this is the most dangerous man in
america
five foot eight hunched over 93 pounds
with gray hair and blue gray skin
if you encounter him keep your distance
i'll do respect sir seems like a lot of
manpower to take down one sweet looking
old man oh he's sweet all right sweet as
poison pie yeah
don't underestimate him i know 28 other
people who did that and they all have
yo-yos swinging from their throats
so you were listening yeah we were
seeing that all along thank you
gentlemen
all right troops traveling toes keep
your eyes open and for god's sake
protect the neck
freeze nypd is that raymond holt's i say
you haven't changed a bit neither of you
ernest
what neither have you ernest
what neither have you
ernest ugh this is hard to watch you're
just as
devious as ever you seduce the van
driver didn't you no
i seduced the van driver she couldn't
resist my groovy voodoo and the yo-yo
string was a message
then what was your what the yo-yo string
was captain this is embarrassing can we
just take him in
yeah you're right this isn't what i
hoped for go ahead and gove him
gently this isn't the last you'll hear
from me raymond i'm never gonna die sure
you won't whatever that makes you feel
better
no you're the punk just put him in the
car
you